hi I'm Francis Collins I'm the director
of the National Institutes of Health in
the United States the question I've
chosen is please tell us what you care
about what future direction you seek and
how he will contribute to improving the
state of the world this is from a lane
Reuters facebook well I'm a physician
and it's part of my job as the director
of the NIH to try to oversee biomedical
research and the largest institution
supports that in the world and one of my
major hopes is that these advances in
medicine which are coming by quickly
will in fact not just benefit the
wealthy but all the peoples of the world
Davos is a place where we come together
to talk about we are making great
strides in terms of understanding the
causes of infectious diseases but in
particular here this year we're talking
a lot about non communicable business
diabetes heart disease obesity cancer
which are becoming more and more common
in right now the major causes of
morbidity and mortality across the world
and what can we do about those things
well many things could be done and
should be done right beginning with
tobacco's which is the cause of a very
great deal of suffering across the world
in which we as a world have so far
failed to completely faced up to and
develop a plan to try to prevent those
kinds of preventable outcomes many other
things though you need to deal with the
issue of infectious diseases right now
we're facing a particular challenge
about influenza is it possible that the
bird flu may find its way that human
populations many discussions about the
appropriate ethical boundaries on
research to look at that one would like
to know answers but also keep people
safe so my hope is in the through the
process of medical research leading to
advances and preventing suffering and
death we could all agree all the peoples
in the world all the faith in the world
seem to have in common the desires
refined sugar that sort of a zucchini
I'm something is necessarily true la voz
is a place where we can focus on these
sales make some progress I can continue
to that in a small way then I'll feel as
if my time here on earth as well